all right good morning everyone so my
name is whitney isila i am the
co-founder of oncopower
which is
a
digital health platform that's geared
towards oncology care and really
connecting patients and physicians and
building
meaningful digital health tools that
sort of simplify the entire care
experience for patients
so we have with us today
dr kinsani i'm going to call her dr t
because i've been struggling a little
bit with her name this morning
and so
dr t is a medical oncologist she's been
practicing for over 20 years
and has been specializing in breast
cancer treatment for the past 12 years
or so
she is board certified in internal
medicine hematology and medical oncology
she earned her medical degree from
muhammad university in in morocco and
she completed an internal medicine
residency at englewood hospital
in new jersey which is an affiliate of
mount sinai school of medicine and then
a fellowship in hematology and oncology
at montefiore in the bronx
she is a medical oncologist with cancer
treatment centers of america in chicago
and um
thank you for joining us today dr t
so you want to tell us a little bit more
about yourself and what drew you towards
oncology care
thank you for having me i think you've
already said enough about me um i'd
like to
um
go ahead and start answering the
questions
okay
i have in the chat room there are a
couple of questions i'd like to start
with and i have another one on my email
so
there is a
woman who shared with her with us
her story and um
asked about
monitoring after diagnosis of breast
cancer this woman had um
stage three triple negative breast
cancer on the right side and
another stage three er positive for two
negative on the left side
she had a lot of mastectomies
and she had her ovaries removed
i do not have information about the
genetics so janet if you're there and
could you confirm whether or not you've
had genetic testing
but
her question is specific about how to be
monitored her doctor
i told her that it's just follow-up
visits and check it up on the symptoms
and the exams and no
scans or testing are necessary
so i want to
enjoy it and so of course somebody who's
had
two sides breast cancer bilateral breast
cancer precept times or at the same time
first thing is genetic
hereditary breast cancer
oh janet said she is barack obama
positive
so uh very important so that's the
reason why for her virginity to have had
both the breasts removed and ovaries
removed monitoring um if you go by the
guidelines and by the standard of care
there is no recommendation to do imaging
studies i think
um
examination talking to our patients
about
any symptoms from head to toe any
headaches shortness of breath cough pain
any new lumps and bumps that would lead
us to do full work up or biopsies or
scans
but without any symptoms there is no
standard of any imaging
studies or any specific blood work that
being said we are very very cautious in
our stage three patients more so than
our staging ones or twos because they're
higher
[Music]
can you say that again
did somebody ask anything
i think somebody was just muting
themselves you can keep going yeah okay
so um
excuse me
however we are very
cautious every time there is any new
symptom
so i tell my patients if i can only
order scans if there is a symptom that
requires a new scan
but i'm quick at doing imaging studies
on my patients i'm concerned about
sometimes it serves us as reassurance
but it's not really a standard to do it
on a routine basis only as needed based
on symptoms
there are some very new things um
in the world of monitoring but it's
really early
there are some studies that are going on
and some are already published in
the literature but it's not standard
again i'm just mentioning it since it's
new it's using circulating tumor dna
uh for monitoring for recurrence we
still don't know how to use the test
very well on what to do with the results
but i just wanted to mention it as an
option in case janet has heard of it and
she was
inquiring specifically about that
so in summary
no imaging unless guided by the clinical
picture anything in the symptoms or
anything in the physical exam would be
quick in doing
monitoring
now in my brachial one positive or
bracket ii positive or any hereditary
breast cancer patients
because the mastectomies do not
really take every single breast cell in
the body in the chest and sometimes
there is residual breast tissue almost
always there is some breast tissue
and anybody with genetic cancer i still
monitor the breasts
after mastectomies mammograms are not
helpful but
mris of the chest
uh
i i recommend them to my breast positive
patients because of the potential
new primary cancers in the chests
whether it's a recurrence of the old
cancer in the same area or an outside of
that
in the residual breast tissue there is a
risk of having few breast cancers in the
breast despite bolero mastectomies and
breast examinations are
continued and i do occasional mris if
i'm able to obtain it in my patients
with mastectomies and back up positivity
another question
um
was from jessica i believe
and then there's a question about
whether the hurt too low are we having a
new medication for it uh there is a new
medication called in in her2
uh which is a a
chemotherapy that's targeted by an
antibody straight to the her2 positive
cells but it showed some benefit even in
patients who have who have her too
low meaning
one plus or two plus so today the
definitions of her two positive disease
is either somebody who has uh her true
three plus by immunohistochemical
meaning when they look in the microscope
with a stain and they find three plus or
two that's definitively positive or if
it's two plus which is considered
intermediate and then confirmed by a
fish test
i know that a lot of breast cancer
patients are familiar with this
terminology
so if there is a
positive the standard of care is to do
her2 target therapies and there are many
options now but if they are
considered negative by the the standard
one plus and two plus are not really
zero they're still somewhere to
expression so they're studies trying to
explore the benefit of this new
medication called in her2
in the her too low and there's some hint
of good activity
in that setting in breast cancer um it's
not really
so far completely standard of care in
her too low patients
definitely not in the early stage in
metastatic setting i believe it will
become a new standard and this category
of her too low it's going to become a
separate category of breast cancer that
would be addressed
not just as a negative her2 but a her2
low and potentially benefit from
specific her to targeted agents just not
standard of care yet stay tuned
um next question
yes
um there was another one
i had a person send an email ahead of
time
well there was one here that's i'm
really interested in from jessica also
about uh the latest of the approval of
verzinio
for early high-risk breast cancer um as
a summary
uh virginia has been approved for a long
time
five years now or so for
stage four or metastatic breast cancer
and it showed incredible activity in
synergy with estrogen receptor uh
blockers or with
full restraint or aromatase inhibitors
um any hormone blockers plus brazilian
had showed very good activity
in metastatic breast cancer so every
time there is a good activity in stage
four the researchers tried to bring it
early on in stage one to stage three
breast cancer meaning given it
with the intention to increase how many
patients we cure of breast cancer and
prevent them from becoming metastatic
which is always the goal um
it has shown that in combination with
aromatase inhibitors
uh
or tamoxifen given for the first two
years of the adjuvant endocrine therapy
it showed a substantial benefit and it
just got an fda approval
meaning our patients who traditionally
will get
surgery followed by chemo followed by
radiation followed by a pill for five
years we'll be getting
two pills for the first two years and
then just continue the the one pill for
five years and sometimes ten years
so um
i am very excited about this i have been
using it in my very high risk patients
just as the study has been published or
talked about in asthma this year so i've
had a few patients on whom i would used
it even a little bit before the fda
approval and i'm very
happy to see that it is approved for
those patients some of these estrogen
receptor positive cancers
are very
difficult to treat because
even though we use chemotherapy
chemotherapy is not as beneficial as
beneficial as it is in some of the
triple negative or the her2 positive
breast cancer so we feel like there was
a gap in really helping those patients
achieve more cures and i think this is
really another step forward
in combination with all the modalities
to increase the cures of er puzzle
breast cancer virginia is overall
tolerable occasionally at first there
are some issues with diarrhea but i tend
to start it a little bit slow i just do
one pill a day for the first few days
make sure there's no severe diarrhea and
go up and we usually manage those side
effects easily with frequent use of an
odium um
from the over the counter
and then good counseling it can also
cause some decrease in the blood count
which is typically not a dangerous thing
most patients tolerate that without any
risk of infections
it requires uh
monitoring of the blood work it can
cause some fatigue but overall we
believe that the benefit outweighs the
risks
um
somebody asked a question about anal
cancer
is it curable and it usually is depends
on the stage but it's there's very high
cure rates if for early stage anal
cancer
um and then
there was an email let's go back to
there's a question about a woman who
really broke my heart because she has
had a history of
dr carcinoma of in situ so which is a
really good prognosis
really
excellent prognosis it's also called
stage zero breast cancer that's
um
cancer cells inside the duct have not
had a chance to break through the
membrane and access
the blood vessels and the risk of
metastasizing so it's still just
localized and typically it's cured with
localized treatments
this woman had had lumpectomy meaning
just excision of the lump plus radiation
standard of care for carcinoma in situ
but typically in those who have
carcinoma in situ and they were hormone
receptor positive estrogen receptor
positive we usually recommend a
pill called tamoxifen to prevent new
invasive cancers in the same breasts or
in the contralateral breast
so i want to reassure
i think that was veronica uh veronique
um
that
the um
the dcis is really a very good prognosis
and
the cure rates with just the surgery and
the radiation therapy are very high
you know the risk of recurrence of dcis
is about 15 to 20 percent based on the
grade and other features the size and
all of it it's not super high the risk
of having any breast cancer in all of us
women is 12
so
slightly higher in women who have had
dcis before
so tamoxifen has been tried to reduce
that risk and it is successful in
reducing the risk of invasive cancer in
the same breast that already had it and
in the contralateral breasts the other
side
but it has not shown any benefit in
survival it didn't really
help people live longer but it's by
taking tamoxifen
so that what it means is
we're watching those patients carefully
so we're able to catch any type of
recurrence whether it's also in situ or
invasive before it it causes any
metastases or
issues and therefore
it is not necessarily offered to every
single person we like to offer
treatments to our patients that are
going to make them help them live longer
so when there's something that does not
increase survival um
their use of it is not necessarily
completely standard on every single
person and it's used on case by case
now
definitely in a person who has
significant side effects the reason i
set my heart breaks for her is because
she has severe migraines
that has really impacted her quality of
life she is incapable to have to work or
to
function and tamoxifen is known to
increase the risk of migraines in
somebody who has a predisposition
so um
the
veronique is worried so she's kind of
i'm scared to stop it because my doctor
told me it's going to reduce my risk by
about 50 of having another event
but at the same time i'm suffering um
again my here is to really reassure you
that
um
dcis has very good prognosis and with
close monitoring it's okay to not take
tamoxifen and monitor because it's
impossible to live in it in that way
no alternatives to tamoxifen
um there's been a study showing that if
you impose menopausal women if you use
aromatase inhibitors and astrozole or
aramidax
um it was
at least as beneficial if not slightly
better than tamoxifen in achieving the
same goals meaning reduction of having a
recurrence in the same breast or
contralateral breast
now if you're not post menopausal there
is a strategy besides removing the
ovaries that can help put a patient into
a menopause which is an injection
that suppresses the ovaries
which is temporarily not as permanent as
removing them surgically and can be
given every four weeks
and it can
allow this person to
still take the preventative medication
to prevent new events but still
hopefully not struggle with migraines
it could be that the migraines are
related to just estrogen uh deprivation
and it may still happen with the other
treatment however i've had some
successes with switching from tamoxifen
to combination of ovarian suppression
and aromatase inhibitors
and not having recurrence of the
migraines or at least it could be better
the other option which is always there
is
do not use anything at all just close
monitoring with mammograms physical
exams
and if any recurrence happens then we
would have we would pick up
early and we will again operate on time
next question
going for a double mastectomy and
reconstruction on monday break up
positive
um
i don't know if there is a question
and then someone said have you heard of
er
erso erso i didn't understand that one
either
please clarify
and add some more information
stage
okay i have a new question joyce
uh i'm a stage four erp or positive and
her2 negative
diagnosed the noble in 2008
mean on femara letrozole since
femara is the same as letrozole
ct scan every six months
i feel that i'm running in borrow time
because we all know someday it will come
back
would you suggest anything to be
proactive thank you
um you know er positive pr positive her2
negative breast cancer can have
some indolent course sometimes meaning
it can be slow progressing or stable for
a long time it can go in the dormant
stage when
the doctor performs scans after scans
and there is no
evidence of disease
and this is very good news and it's when
we have those patients we are very glad
to take care of them because we get to
see them
have a very normal life despite the
stage for cancer so this is not so
unusual
to continue to enjoy as normal life as
possible on the treatment same treatment
for a very long time
i do want to make sure that we monitor
our patients very very closely
at the time when there was the diagnosis
just started an aromatase inhibitor was
the standard of care at that time in all
postmenopausal women
about six years ago
uh
adding cdk for six inhibitors has become
the standard of care
um however in somebody who's already
benefiting and having no significant
progression of their cancer
i don't see a reason to change anything
at this time
um
uh we like we have this basket of
options that we like to use very wisely
and carefully so we can extend the
options as long as we can
so
even though our that we have available
new options
there's no reason to use them up if the
current treatment is working well
sometimes i do combine ct scans with
bone scans because sometimes
the combination of the two can be more
accurate in detecting
lesions in the bone also occasionally i
can build pet scan that can also be a
test to make sure we're not missing if
you have any concerns about missing
something
but if clinically on the laboratory
tests and the studies there is no
evidence of progression of the cancer
i would not change anything at this time
while dr t teased up the next question
there was um
a sort of a question adjacent to what
we're talking about um
regarding it was the same person that
asked about
the curability of anal cancer they asked
about programs
with no insurance and i just want to
direct that user onto anchorpower.org
join our our
our community and pose it there because
there's really a ton of resources in
terms of people that have gone through
exactly what you're going through and we
will help you find exactly uh what it is
that you need for support
amanda asks us a general question i
appreciate very much when our aromatase
inhibitors use and what is their purpose
so aromatase inhibitors are a type of
estrogen
estrogen deprivation therapy
so this
typically there are different groups of
the way we treat estrogen-driven breast
cancer so
estrogen-driven breast cancer is really
the majority of all breast cancers
um two-thirds or so are
estrogen-driven and
meaning the cancer cells have these
estrogen receptors that
are driving the growth of the cancer and
we use that feature
to target um
the treatment and
kill the cancer cells
we have an option the traditional oldest
treatment we have the oldest targeted
therapy really is tamoxifen which blocks
the receptors of the estrogen
in some of other tissues it's really a
partial agonist of the receptors or the
modulator of the receptors
and then we
that is really something that works on
breast cancer whether the woman is in a
puzzle or not because it doesn't really
do anything to the production
it works with the receptors peripherally
um and then after that we had
thermostats inhibitors now i think
they've been since the 90s
and what they do is
they
they use the production they work on the
production of
estrogen that happens outside of the
ovaries so the main producer of estrogen
are the ovaries in pre-menopausal women
after menopause when the ovaries don't
make any more estrogen
uh electrolyte patients we don't really
turn into men we still have uh estrogen
in our bodies and it is um
produced in some precursors estrogen are
produced in the adrenal gland
and they are transformed into estrogen
using this enzyme called aromatase so by
inhibiting the enzyme we prevent the
production we stop the production of
estrogen that's driven by the adrenal
glands and that
transformation of the precursors of
estrogen to estrogen via this enzyme
happen in multiple tissues of the body
sometimes
um
and
for example in the liver in some of the
fatty tissue in peripheral tissues so
it's an enzyme
that helps producing
estrogen in the body in postmenopausal
women we block that enzyme therefore we
block that estrogen feed to the cancer
it is used in early breast cancer
meaning between stage one and stage
three
after having surgery as a prevention of
a recurrence
this is part of the treatment it has
really improved the prognosis
substantially because if there are any
microscopic cells that have survived in
the body
it allows them to go into a dormant
state or completely kill them
so it is it really is a big success in
increasing cure rates of early stage er
positive breast cancer it is also the
main treatment that we started most of
our patients with er positive breast
cancer that has already metastasized or
stage four
and it can be used either alone but in
stage four they are now used in
conjunction with the cdk46 inhibitors
and there are three of them out there
and the doctors and the patient decide
together on which one to use and the
combination really can be very
successful in the initial treatments of
all stage four patients
i'm gonna go look for another question
what are pros and cons for her to three
plus to get hysterectomy
should this be done as preventive for
recurrence
and
um
really the
association between
a hysterectomy and i'm assuming that
it's a total hysterectomy which
has the intention to really remove the
ovaries
it's typically treatment that is
suggested in estrogen-positive breast
cancer as part of the treatment or it
could be a risk reduction strategy in
women who have a high risk of hereditary
hereditary mutation that can increase
the risk of ovarian cancer or uterine
cancer
um in that situation
we
ask our patients to
get a hysterectomy but in estrogen it's
an indication for estrogen receptor
positive patients to
treat them
because if we put them into a menopausal
state by removing the ovaries we can
have them receive aromatase inhibitors
as opposed to using tamoxifen
and that's because the combination of
menopause plus aromatase inhibitors is
slightly more effective than tamoxifen
alone in those patients
but i do not see the reason
um to remove the ovaries
in a estrogen negative breast cancer and
in a patient who does not have
hereditary mutation
so i'm not sure if the question was
intended to say er positive or her too
she said her to three plus
there must be some missing information
that could justify why her doctors are
recommending hysterectomy or why she's
considering it but with just that
information it's not possible to comment
monika i have been diagnosed with
invasive ductal carcinoma grade two
estrogen positive so this is
um invasive cancer agreed
skeptic grade two
hysterectomy about five years ago
justin positive but they let my ovaries
left my ovaries
would it be recommended
to have my ovaries removed now i'm
59 years old
okay
um
so i am five years ago monica was
54 years old which means already
potentially post-menopausal
i do not know if
monica was recommended hysterectomy
because of any concerns about a genetic
condition that can increase the risk of
other cancers
sometimes doctors would recommend
hysterectomies if somebody is on
tamoxifen because tamoxifen can increase
the risk of cancer of the uterus and if
a person is on tamoxifen uh if there is
a risk if there is bleeding or thickness
in the line of the uterus sometimes a
hysterectomy is is is performed to
prevent the risk of cancer of uterus
uh because here the the ovaries were
remaining in place which means we were
not worried about the ovaries
uh in terms of production of estrogen
because she was already post-menopausal
i do not see any value to remove the
ovaries now in the absence of any
hereditary condition that increases the
risk of ovarian cancer because the
ovaries are not responsible for making
estrogen at this time
new question i have mmt ovarian cancer
that mixed malaria
tumor ovarian cancer
who is bracha 2 positive what would be a
recommendation for double mastectomy for
preventative treatment tammy
so um
braca 2 positive breast cancer
there is a high risk of having
new breast cancers even in somebody who
never had it before
between broccoli one broccoli to the
risk of having breast cancer can be
between 30 and up to 80 percent bracket
to a little bit less than bracha one
so it's high enough
that preventative surgery
is highly
recommended um
then
the recommendation usually depends on if
the person has ovarian cancer already
what is the stage of the cancer is it
cured with surgery or having uh high
chances of cure with surgery with or
without chemo or is it an advanced
ovarian cancer in which case the focus
is to treat that ovarian cancer as
opposed to preventing
new cancers assuming that the ovarian
cancer was early stage and it was
treated with surgery and
all the necessary treatments and person
has a very good prognosis it would be
highly recommended to do preventative
surgeries for the breasts to prevent any
new breast cancers in a bracket-positive
patient
do you know of any medications to
prevent reoccurrence in people with
genetic marker for lynch syndrome
so lynch syndrome is a genetic condition
that increases the risk of multiple
cancers the highest ones are colon
cancer
and
urine cancer of the endometrium or the
uterus
it is some it is the main prevention in
patients with lynch syndrome
is to do surgeries preventative
surgeries
um meaning removing
subtotal colectomies and removing the
uterus preventively
there is no specific medication
oral medication or intravenous
medication or no chemical that would
help prevent
um
recurrence that's unique to the lynch
syndrome but their cancers should be
prevented and treated similar to other
cancers
whether they're lynched or not for
example if a person with lynch
has a cancer of the uterus then that
person will be treated with the same
treatments that other patients with
cancer of the uterus would have had
and if somebody had a colon cancer it's
the same thing if somebody with lynch
syndrome have had breast cancer which i
have seen
they also should be treated
in a very similar way a typical breast
cancer person should be treated with
there is no uniqueness to the lynch
syndrome except for the high risk of the
other cancers
that should be screened for and
potentially preventively
operated on
i'm just going over to questions to make
sure i didn't miss anybody's question
uh to go back to a question that jessica
asked about the er
so or erso i am not really aware of that
medication and she mentioned that um it
is not in clinical trials yet
so i'm really not aware of it so i would
not be
able to answer your question but you
have i'm happy to connect with you and
uncle power later on if this becomes a
real thing and
we would be offering it to our patients
this is great dr t we really appreciate
you uh taking the time to go through all
the questions for
for our participants
it's my pleasure i hope it's helpful and
um
it looks like we have a new question
yes
new message
yes very good question i think uh
jessica again asked us if a patient or a
person who has lynch syndrome benefit
from lymphazone so lympha is a one of
the medications are available for a
different condition
it's a part inhibitor you may have heard
of parp inhibitors are indicated
in a patient who have brachial positive
cancers
and not just breast cancer now it's
approved in a lot of different cancers
related to the bracha gene
um
it is not something that is indicated in
lynch syndrome because the genetic
abnormality and the deficit that those
cancer cells have in the dna repair
mechanisms that's what lympha and its
family of drugs target the dna the dna
repair genes and um
the the deficiency is different in lynch
syndrome and therefore
the lympha and the prop inhibitors are
not
uh indicated in that situation
now i understand why you asked about a
medication for lynch syndrome you were
thinking the park inhibitors but those
are unique to the braca mutations and
similar mutations to the baraka that are
in the same uh pathway affect the same
dna repair areas of the gene and it's uh
for example the atm mutation can respond
to that and probably two mutations can
respond to the prep inhibitors but the
highest responses are for the bracha
genes not for the lynch syndrome
are they
any way you could explain the pdl
mind came back positive
my tumor is also chemo resistance
so we started immunotherapy from crystal
it's a very good topic the pdl one
so for the last few years
immunotherapy has been
very
popular in a lot of different cancers it
has been improved in
i think 80 different indications
but
breast cancer has also been part of
those success stories specifically the
triple negative breast cancer
we have an approval for using
immunotherapy in stage four triple
negative breast cancers but most
recently in the early stage um triple
negative breast cancers
before surgery
and for up to nine treatments after
surgery
so
the specific one that is approved
um
so i want to explain i think crystal
wants to understand
maybe how it works and
um what's the benefit so pdl1
antibodies they're really antibodies
what they do is
they try to alert the immune system and
recruit the immune cells and teach them
that these cells here are cancerous the
cancer cells they are foreign bodies
and you need to attack them
if you could think of the immune the
cancer cells are just our normal cells
but they have changed a little bit and
some of them change a lot some of them
change a little bit but most of them
are not detected by our immune system as
a foreign body the same way our immune
system will detect
uh
a a bacteria or a virus or something and
goes and attacks it it detects the
cancer cells as just another normal cell
of the body and it leaves it alone
so the pdl1 antibodies the immune
therapies available today
this type of immunotherapy called the
checkpoint inhibitors
they go and remove that disguise that
the cancer cells have as normal cells
and expose them as the bad guy to the
immune system and the immune system
therefore will
hopefully a good percentage of the cases
will attack them successfully
and
the the good news about immunotherapy is
when when they work in samara patients
majority of the time they will work for
substantial amount of time um we could
sometimes speak about cure in stage four
patients who would never heard of before
we have seen some amazing situations
when
chemo resistance after chemo resistance
after chemo resistance and then the pdl
one antibodies came up and we okay we
have no other choices let's try them in
somebody with pdl1 receptor positivity
and those patients who have the positive
receptors have higher chances of
responding intuitively and and then we
see that all of a sudden the patient
responds so
unfortunately the instead
how common that happens is not as common
as we'd like it to be
sometimes it's between 15 to 25
of the overall people could respond
however um
some responses can be very successful
also the other good thing about them is
they don't really have the usual side
effects that our patients have struggled
with
from chemotherapy meaning if somebody
has already had a lot of chemo side
effects
this changes this changes completely
because the side effects of the
immunotherapy are very different than
the side effect of the chemo so there's
no additional uh like neuropathy on top
of neuropathy or
does not cause the hair loss so it would
be
um
a little bit of a change it's not
without side effects but they are very
different and they're not as common
so immunotherapy and triple negative
breast cancer is really a success story
both in early stage increases the
chances of cures but also in the
metastatic disease where it could be
used with chemotherapy at first and then
the chemotherapy stops and then the
immunotherapy continues in those who
respond well to it
so for our patient here um
our question was
yes crystal
um
so i hope that you will really we will
be one of those really super responders
to the immunotherapy and your outcome
will be excellent i really wish you the
best we would love to hear from you
again about your outcome
another question
i think this one is a lymphoma question
diffuse large b cell lymphoma
it is really not a breast cancer
question i would love to
support you outside of this platform
since this is a breast cancer
question and answers but
you can ask the question
in a private
platform in the same site if you don't
mind
so our same patient who asked about
ovarian cancer
is following up with another question
mmt ovarian cancer stage 3a i forgot to
say that i'm just having last round of
chemo next week already had full
hysterectomy
skipped
and everything removed i will start a
metro prevention soon i am not clear
on the fact that things were removed and
chemo has been done
and scans are clear why do they say the
cancer is not curable but controllable
okay
no uh tammy nmt ovarian cancer stage
three is curable situation however
one two three four the higher the stage
the percentages of cures go down by
stage
so the stage four is considered
incurable today
but i'm not gonna i'm just saying now
that there are some cures still based on
immunotherapy responses in some
situations but in general stage four is
considered incurable one two three
curable however the percentages of cures
decrease as we go up on a stage
and then t ovarian cancer
is a histology meaning subtype of
ovarian cancer
that is that is a poor prognosis overall
even though in early stages
and in ovarian cancer we have
um
the parp inhibitors
have been really standard of care
whether the patient has a bracha
mutation or not they have shown a very
good benefit in a maintenance strategy
after surgery and after
uh the chemotherapy has been completed a
maintenance strategy with the prop
inhibitors is now standard of care in
ovarian cancer now i know this is an
over uncancer question but it is
involving the parp inhibitors i believe
that's what the doctor is intending to
give um tammy a pill uh to prevent a
recurrence so when we say
um
we're giving you you you do very well
your cancer is all removed so this is
really general question all the patients
struggle with everybody struggles with
this so my cancer was in place in the
ovary or the breast or any part of the
body we took it out with surgery why do
i need all this stuff the cancer is
removed so now i want to explain
something the cancer think of the cancer
before it's removed it's sitting in any
organ in the body it has all the blood
flow and all the lymphatics going
through it
it is really um
what we're trying to treat after
removing the cancer
isn't the cancer that was already
removed we're trying to treat any
microscopic cells that might have hopped
on the bloodstream or a lymphatic
circulation while the tumor was still in
the original spot before it was removed
some microscopic cells can travel and go
into the bloodstream and then go
somewhere you may not see them today you
might not see them by our current
uh strategies which is cat scans pet
scans you may not see those microscopic
cells because we don't have a microscope
inside the bloodstream to look for them
so but they can either die after the
surgery because of the chemo and that's
the purpose of the chemo or they can
hide somewhere and then five ten years
later two years later they can show up
either in the lung or the liver or the
bones or
the brain or anyone in the body so
that's the purpose of all the systemic
treatments the oncologists give after
removing the cancer or sometimes before
removing the cancer the intention
is not necessarily to kill the cancer
itself because that's going to be
removed with surgery it's the cancer is
to kill those floaters i call them the
floaters that travel in the bloodstream
that we can't see
so some the doctors don't know if you
have them and they don't know if the
treatment is killing them because they
are microscopic but we know from doing
studies on large populations of patients
that those patients who have received
treatment after surgery had higher cure
rates than those who did not and that ex
tells us that the treatment we give
kills those microscopic cells in a good
percentage of the patients at least good
enough to lead to this treatment
becoming standard of care and that's why
after doing surgery get chemo and
sometimes we get this maintenance
protocol i encourage my patient i tell
them you know the it's a good thing to
have that maintenance as a safety
blanket or as a shield from having that
recurrence if it's effective it is
keeping any microscopic cells dormant
maybe killing them and it will increase
the chances of never seeing the
recurrence from this cancer
hopefully this explain tammy's a
question
and then there is another one do you
foresee a place for immunotherapy
hormone positive or too low breast
cancer very good question um
so far this results of
her immunotherapy in er positive breast
cancer was not very high
the numbers were
too low to to be encouraging or becoming
a standard of care
that being said it wasn't zero there
still are some er positive patients who
still respond to immunotherapy so a lot
of research is ongoing to try to find
how do we find those who will be
responding how do we um
are there any biomarkers are there any
features of those er positive breast
cancers
um or her too low which is now a new
terminology we're going to be getting
used to
can we find
the num the patient who would be
responding
to um
her immunotherapy now there's
encouraging information about her2
positive and immunotherapy it really was
encouraging in studies in gastric cancer
gastric cancer can be her two positives
also
and they found that combining
chemotherapy with herceptin and adding
in immunotherapy really showed some
great results
so maybe in her2 positive
breast cancer the
may be a think of the near future in er
positive the researchers are still
looking for biomarkers to try to find
those amongst er positive breast cancers
that have potential of responding and
not just treating everyone and when they
did that the responses were low
not not high enough to justify the
potential side effects at this time
i think that's all of the live questions
we have coming in for now if anyone
wants to continue to submit we'll keep
an eye on the chat
but dr t i love your
your take on some of what's happening in
healthcare in terms of telehealth and
digital tools and
even just drug development and whatnot
in oncology and and you know what tools
you have in the toolbox for seeing your
patients
i'm sorry is that a question
yeah
a commentary on
you know what
what you um are seeing in oncology care
and in healthcare right now in terms of
digital health and telehealth
as well as that you know just the sheer
amount of treatments and drugs that are
coming out to to help these patients yes
really oncology has exploded just um
i did my fellowship between 2004 and
2007 and just between then and now
it is a completely different field uh in
every single subtype of cancer it is
becoming very difficult to be the expert
in every single type of cancer because
the literature
and the the new drugs and the approvals
are really um
very fast and happening very quickly
it's very good for our patients it's
excellent we are so excited
to see new options in every single
cancer some type of breast cancer or
other
areas
so the the development drug development
is really very encouraging
there are also new things in the way we
monitor our patients hopefully we change
and improve upon what we have today
um
in terms of the
this remote access that patients have
really benefited from
i found it to be really one of the few
positive things from the pandemic is we
have learned how to
manage the distance and how to offer
care advice
follow-ups um remotely i feel like
oncology is one of the fields that is
very amenable to remote uh care second
opinions just having advice
because it really depends on reviewing
the records
and and just give it an opinion so i do
do a lot of this with my own clinic
patients if they are traveling patients
from far away and they just need to
check in some side effects with me we
can do a visit remotely like this and we
it feels very natural it feels
um we feel the connection through the
video call
and also in
people internationally i mean the
international reach we can have in
giving patients reassurance second
opinions advice we can advise patients
we can advise their doctors they can
connect with us
while they're in the doctor's visit to
have a discussion
it is the era of patient-centered care
it's all about our patients we don't
just prescribe things and tell them what
to do we have a discussion about the
options and we
tell them explain to them why we're
recommending our recommendation and
what's the data and having really that
collaboration with the local doctors the
patient have or with the patients
directly
i think is huge positive and i'm excited
about the international patients as well
because
there is discrepancies unfortunately
amongst the whole world in how things
are done and access for the world
throughout patients to care or to the
new drugs is not really
uniform and
having increasing the awareness of
what's going on in the world and what's
going on here it was the new things to
patients all over the world will help
access help increase the access to these
people and um
maybe they will have advocacy groups
service and these patients in this
country are getting immunotherapy for
this cancer we don't have access to it
and being aware of what's going on is
really information is always powerful
and it increases
the education of the patients and the
people affected with cancer
absolutely
so we don't have any further questions
coming through um question jessica has
been really uh very a great participant
unless there's so many very a lot of
jessica's but i think he's the same
person thank you jessica very much for
your participation it really kept the
discussion going um
have you ever seen a stage four patient
cancer patient cured absolutely i have
uh i really wish i could have some of my
cured patients on this in this forum
right now to talk to and uh give some
encouraging messages to our other
patients but uh i have uh had seen some
patients who
one of them i can think of because
they're
really just a very amazing story who
had been with me for a very long time
with triple negative breast cancer who
had
multiple lines of therapy
uh i believe we had up to nine different
lines of different chemos over the years
and every time the cancer comes back
give us a short-term benefit and then
recurse everything we give but i believe
those lines of therapies have allowed us
to
stay around until immunotherapy came out
and it was still very very early it had
already
only been approved in
melanoma at that time
so we used it because we had no other
choices and the person was still very
strong and healthy and still wanted to
keep trying so we had it compassionate
to use access
um we obtained immunotherapy to her and
she had an incredible response i think
now we are
four or five years
without any evidence of disease
and we have stopped immunotherapy after
using this for two to three years
and then she's still disease-free and i
really strongly believe that she's done
with this cancer
and that she will never hear from it
again and she's cured i have another one
who had
metastases in the sternum that was
uncomfortable painful we treated it with
radiation we treated with other
treatments and we cut had some
resistance and recurrence so
she did not have a lot of treatment this
one she had only maybe one or two
different mods of therapy and she did
not tolerate the treatment at all
and then we had immunotherapy and she
even had side effects from that but she
ended up receiving at least three or
four treatments and then so far maybe
also four or five years later and there
is no evidence of disease
um
this is um
unfortunately not very common but it can
happen it makes it worthwhile to give it
a try in the triple negative breast
cancer
and that's why it got approved because
we have seen cures
it's hard to call it cure because it's
so early it's still only a few years
even the patients were treated
first in clinical trials or even of
label use are only now about five to six
years after but still it is a long-term
benefit that we have not seen before on
standard chemotherapies
question from tony can you take cbd and
virginia at the same time
i mean i'm not really very knowledgeable
about the use of cbd we there's somebody
some good naturopathic people out there
that can help our patients with
interactions
but
i personally don't see um any overlap
there in terms of
any overlapping why wouldn't they work
together or why would they be any
toxicities of the two together but i
don't claim to be experts on this
next question triple negative breast
cancer
if it does return
where in the body does this type of
cancer typically return
janet as i mentioned earlier
when when the cancer returns it really
doesn't really go away it never went
away microscopic cells have survived in
the body menindee had escaped from the
original tumor before it was removed and
they go through the bloodstream and
since the blood flows in every part of
the body
any part any recurrence anywhere in the
body where the blood goes is a
possibility
that being said um
the common ones we see are
um
triple negative disease
tends to go to the organs as opposed to
the er positive where it's commonly goes
in the bones first
so i've seen triple negative patients
with lung and liver metastases at the
same time lung or liver
pleural effusion which is a lining
around
the lungs that can accumulate some fluid
another location is the brain it's it's
not an uncommon a her2 positive breast
cancer
is the number one that goes into the
brain more commonly than the others but
i've seen it
not infrequently in triple negative
patients
um
so the organ so we call it typically
bone-only metastases which is more
common in estrogen receptor positive
cancers and we have visceral disease
when it's in the organs like the lungs
and the liver the lymph nodes or the
brain
i've seen it in the skin superficial
skin metastasis nodules typically in the
chest area
but it can be also in the back or
other areas but in the chest wall and on
the surface of the skin is another
location that we see not uncommonly but
again anywhere where the blood flows
microscopic cells can go in and
metastasize
any questions yeah
yeah
well dr t thank you so much for your
time and expertise today it has been
such a pleasure to be able to to get
your insight on on all of these
questions
oh you're welcome anytime
i think tony asked the question about
some natural remedies that are out there
i'm really not
i don't have expertise in these things
to be honest and i really really rely on
my
natural specialist colleagues to help
with these questions
but i have not personally seen anybody
cured successfully with
anything outside of the conventional
oncology treatments
well said
all right well thank you everyone for
joining our
our first ask a doc live
we want to thank dr t again for her time
and expertise and we look forward to
many more sessions with a variety of
specialists so that we can sort of keep
this expertise coming at you thank you
so much and everyone have a great
weekend
thank you